ces lions bonsoir vous avez une somme
pas particulièrement critiques à votre
égard je vais ajouter aux louanges aura
ou encore pour ses victoires de la
musique
et merci de nous avoir réservé
l'exclusivité de cet album en anglais
pour une chanteuse québécoise céline ça
correspond à quoi d'enregistrer en
anglais ben écoutez moi c'était mon rêve
bon j'ai commencé à chanter j'avais cinq
ans j'avais quand même une grande vision
du show-business moi je voulais chanter
en français je voulais chanter en
anglais même peut-être dans d'autres
langues
je voulais avoir une carrière qu'on
appel international pour chanter pour
plus de monde possible et j'ai commencé
ma carrière en chantant en français
c'est sûr parce que je suis nue j'étais
entouré à la maison on parlait
uniquement français j'ai commencé à
enregistrer mon premier dit j'avais 13
ans en france et bien sûr et un moment
donné j'ai commencé à faire ma première
tournée de spectacles quand j'avais 14
ans au québec plein moment de niche avec
une chanson en anglais dans mon
répertoire et chanter war fut tout le
monde dansait avec moi je comprenais
rien de ce que je chantais puis je me
suis dit j'aimerais bien là l'école pour
prendre des cours d'anglais alors il ya
peu très vite en jeu fils à l'école
j'ai pris des cours d'anglais parce que
j'avais envie de le faire et maintenant
je me considère vraiment chanceuse parce
que je peux faire les deux j'ai comme
deux carrières c'est pas chez vous au
québec considéré comme une trahison
absolument pas parce que je pense que
les gens du québec ont toujours été là
pour moi ils savaient à quel point
j'avais des grands rêves puis sont
toujours est il que me supporter alors
tout le monde parle de cette voix
magnifique qui est la vôtre c'est une
voix qui qui vous est naturel ou est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous avez
infiniment travail et je pense que j'ai
eu quand même dans mais quand tu es 50
était entouré d'instruments de musique
était entourée de chanteurs parce que
moi maîtresses frères et mes soeurs mes
parent ou 14 réseaux chante aussi
moi je suis le bébé de la famille puis
tout le monde chante dans ma famille mes
parents
partez en tournée de spectacles avec mes
frères et mes soeurs et c'est la seule
chose que je connaisse vraiment de
chanter toute ma vie c'est je sors je me
rappelle on mettait sur la table de la
salle de 2,2
la cuisine je faisais des spectacles
pour mes frères fumer ça alors je vous
connais à peu près c'est une dure depuis
une demi heure maintenant et ça me
confirme ce qu'on m'avait dit tout le
monde dit que vous êtes une grande star
vous vendez 10 millions de disques et
vous êtes toujours simple mais pas
écouter ce que je peux vous répondre
c'est que je fais pas ce métier là pour
devenir quelqu'un d'autre je trouve bien
dans ma peau
moi je pense que j'ai tout eu parce que
j'ai eu des parents les frères et des
soeurs qui on est entouré d'amour tout
le temps puis je veux avoir la tête dans
les nuages parce que je vis quand même
un rêve extraordinaire mais je pense que
j'ai les deux pieds sur terre alors
dernière chose là vous parlez depuis
quatre minutes maintenant avec interplay
l'accent lorsque vous chantez en
français vous n'avez pas l'action du
tout je vais vous dire là je pense que
ça fait quinze ans que j'essaie de
comprendre comment ça se fait que je
parle avec un accent implique un
changement n'est pas juste je peux même
pas vous répondre je sais pas pourquoi
je me force pas qu'un chapeau pour que
ça sonne le français je comprends pas
merci merci en tout cas là toujours
maintenu merci de votre gentillesse
voilà ce journal